لدينا خطه بهذا الصدد نحاول مساعده
الاطفال ولا سيما الاطفال الذين فقدوا
اهاليهم باعتبار ذلك اولويه لانهم في
اوضاع هشه للغايه نعمل كذلك بالتعاون مع
المتطوعين على الارض من خلال الهلال
الاحمر السوري ولكن نرى ايضا ان هناك
مفقودون احيانا
الاباء والامهات وكذلك الاطفال يكونون
مفقودين ويمكن ان تتصل بمكتبنا وتقدم طلبا
لتعقب هؤلاء المفقودين ونبذل قصار جهدنا
بالتعاون مع الشركاء لاعطاء اجوبه على هذه
الاسئله تتصورين مدى الالم الذي يشعر به
اولئك الذين يفقدون احبائهم ونحاول ان لما
شتاته نصر المشتته هذه الكارثه الطبيعيه
الحقيقه اخذت الاضواء على المستوى
الاخباري من كارثه اخرى تقع في العالم
الان الحرب في اوكرانيا
مر سنه على هذه الحرب ما هو تقييمكم للوضع
الانساني هناك